[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here we're back
and yeah you got me i've been using the
oneplus 8 pro
daily for about two weeks now and i
gotta say
they did it they finally did it they
just went ahead and made a flagship like
a bonafide complete feeling
flagship
phone finally now there are still a few
snags and i will nitpick about those
because that's what you do in a phone
that starts now at 900 bucks
but still nevertheless really happy to
see them finally commit to something
like this and it's been a long time
coming so today as you may have seen
oneplus launched their newest highest
end phone it's the oneplus 8 pro taking
yet another step up in the ladder of
their phones getting slightly more
expensive every year but alongside it
they also dropped the oneplus 8 which is
sort of more like a premium mid-range
phone that starts at 6.99 so that that
will be its own separate video that will
come out later once i fully daily drive
this phone switch to it give it that
treatment um
that's going to be a tough video to make
without all kinds of reflections but
definitely subscribe to see that video
first when it comes out hit the red
button below if you haven't already
that's coming up but until then we're
talking about this guy the eight pro
the flagship so the bleeding edge high
end specs shouldn't be a surprise when
we see a new one plus phone i mean
beside the fact that they slowly tease
out all the specs the weeks leading up
to the phone's launch it's kind of what
they're known for you know placing what
feels like the highest and best
available specs for the highest end
performance all in one phone and we
still have a very familiar oneplus
design and experience here too they
still have their logo on the back and
still things like the alert slider that
i'm surprised more phones haven't copied
yet still oxygen os one of my favorite
clean android skins with all of its
features but wait stop pause what have
the nitpicks always been with oneplus
phones
one is that their cameras are always
just not quite measuring up to the
flagships
and two
that they always tend to leave out these
sort of fringe features that don't feel
essential but still feel like you should
have them if you're gonna claim that
you're a flagship things like wireless
charging and ip68 certification well
guess what they finally went and added
this year
an improved camera
wireless charging
and an official ip68 water and dust
resistance rating finally but you know
what let me start from the top with the
new design for the oneplus 8 pro you can
see it here i really like a lot of it uh
the new matte finish and this blue color
are pretty sick i don't have a lot of
matte blue phones but this one is nice
it's punchy and clean so it's easily my
favorite blue phone and this finish is
nice it doesn't really show too many
fingerprints of course you can also grab
this ultra matte tear down skin from our
channel sponsor dbrand which also feels
great and you can see the wireless
charging coil in the back plus it's also
got a few easter eggs hidden in the
design which are pretty dope but anyway
yeah the shape of the phone is boxy
which i've always really liked plus
there's this new little design accent
ridge into the top of the phone so
generally i think it's one of the
absolute better looking phones out there
but i still get to nitpick because like
i said 900 phone that's what's gonna
happen this camera bump while it's not
as ugly as some of the others out there
it still is pretty big like it's
annoyingly rocks on a table big for
sticking out of the phone that much so i
gotta point that out
but again you can put a case on it and
get rid of that
then you get around to the front and
you're looking at the new display which
is an upgrade to pretty much all the
ways that count but also technically
technically a slight downgrade too so
this is a 6.78 inch 1440p
120 hertz
amoled display and it's really really
good oneplus and displaymates say it's
their most color accurate display ever
you know the best a plus they've ever
given etc etc they're kind of starting
to sound a lot like dxomark at this
point look i believe you the color's
great the calibration is great but what
i notice more often is number one it's
definitely a lot brighter than last year
which is sweet and then of course the
flagship feature for 2020 for all these
new flagships which is the smooth 120
hertz refresh rate plus 240 hertz touch
sampling rate and it is awesome i've
been looking forward to this couple
specifics on it one yes it does let you
run both high refresh rate and high
resolution
at the same time and that's exactly what
i've been doing 1440p at 120 hertz at
the expense of battery but you know live
your life
then yes it is technically a variable
refresh rate so even when you have it
set to 120 hertz just like last year it
will step down to 60 hertz occasionally
when you're just sitting around not
doing anything or if you're on a home
screen or if you're in some app that
won't use that like waze or google maps
or snapchat or a game or something
then yes there is still an optical
fingerprint reader underneath that
screen it doesn't appear to be any
bigger or faster but still fairly
reliable for me
and yes
the edges are still curved over both
sides and this is my least favorite
feature of this display
i still get accidental touches like
really i i realize the idea is it looks
cool and it's edgeless and futuristic
but i think it's time to slow that down
and i think samsung's perfected that
balance this year between curving the
glass a little bit and still having a
flat working surface with no accidental
touches so just saying and also by now
from all these beauty angles of the
screen certainly you've noticed that
hole punch camera in the top left corner
for the selfie shooter for the oneplus 8
pro hot take
the pop-up camera
was
the pop-up camera was better
than the hole punch and this is a
downgrade like i get that the pop-up
camera was a moving part i was the first
to point that out a moving part and a
phone is always a part to pay attention
to but we haven't had any durability
problems with them for the past two
years we've seen them in phones
and of course having that part hidden
inside allows you a fully uninterrupted
screen with no hole punch and when it
closes down into the phone and you're
not using it it's blocked by the rest of
the phone so that's an added security
benefit
so it seems like the pop-up camera was
the way to go so why do they remove the
pop-up camera and change back to a hole
punch
i don't know maybe to look a little bit
more like the other flagships maybe to
save a little bit of money maybe maybe
to guarantee the ip68 water
certification maybe just a little bit of
all these things also side note
i would like to see some of these phones
offering 120 hertz screens
also offer a 90 hertz mode in between 60
and 120. so we already know we can step
down to 1080p to save battery life i
think it would be nice to be able to
step down to 90 hertz to save battery
life too
just an idea some of the gaming phones
have done this already but i want to see
more flagships doing it too so there's a
free idea so all of the oneplus 8
internal specs are high end top end you
know snapdragon 865 8 or 12 gigs of fast
lpddr5 ram it's that super fast ufs 3.0
storage
and the battery also gets an upgrade
because on top of all that it's a 5g
capable phone with 120 hertz big display
so you get a 4 510 milliamp hour battery
it's not the biggest battery in the
world but for me it did just fine like i
said i've been using the phone with my
high brightness high gps use at 1440p
120 hertz and i've been getting to the
end of the day pretty comfortably i
could kill this phone in a day and i've
noticed that but if i didn't want to i
would step down to 1080p and i would
save a lot of pixel pushing and a lot of
battery and that's a nice backup to have
generally for me i'm talking about like
a six hour screen on time for this phone
six and a half hours if you want to
reference back to other videos that's
really good uh but also something to
note is for me
the charging habits of your phone can
change what you think of the battery and
oneplus phones are known for having fast
charging this one's no exception you
still have their high speed warp charge
30t comes in the box
and that can get you from zero to half
battery in like 25 minutes but what's
new to this phone is
wireless charging finally oneplus is
putting the little charging coil behind
the glass back and enabling wireless
charging and on top of all that even
better it's fast wireless charging so 30
watt wireless charging is what they're
claiming and sharing with everyone which
is
really nice that's fast that's going to
top up from zero to half battery in half
an hour
but
there's a catch you only get
fast 30 watt wireless charging with this
phone
with
this exact s brand new 70 dollar one
plus
wireless charging stand you need this
accessory to get 30 watts wireless
charging on this phone and that's
because it is not 30 watts of purely qi
wireless charging so oneplus has worked
on this special high-end wireless
charging tech and to be fair it works
exactly as advertised the stand is nice
it has some little quiet fans in there
and it does some special voltage and
thermal management to get the peak 30
watts wireless charging out of it but if
you put another qi enabled phone on that
wireless charger it charges slower and
if you put the oneplus 8 pro on any
other qi wireless charger it charges
slower because that tech was proprietary
so the oneplus 8 pro still supports
regular qi wireless charging but only
universally at 5 watts
which is pretty slow it's not it's i
mean it works but it's like it's pretty
slow so for me
i'm not going to replace the you can't
see it but i'm not going to replace the
wireless charger at my desk with the
oneplus one because i have other qi
accessories like my airpods pro or my
iphone or literally any other chi phone
that i want to charge faster wirelessly
so i'm just going to stick to wired warp
charging in the car and pretty much
everywhere i need it but at home i have
a pixel stand at my desk and i can just
leave it there to slowly top up
overnight and wake up with 100 so i'm
glad to have wireless charging but that
there is that little snag so then there
are the cameras quad cameras on the back
of this phone and here are the numbers
which maybe mean less than ever these
days but it's a new 48 megapixel main
camera with ois then there's a 48
megapixel ultra wide with macro mode
which fun fact is the same sensor as the
primary camera from the oneplus 7 pro
then there's a 3x telephoto camera and
believe it or not the fourth one is a 5
megapixel color filter camera so that's
your array and i'll just go ahead and
say it the oneplus 8 pro is a flagship
quality camera right in line with galaxy
s20 and huawei p40 and just short of the
pixel and the iphone
there i said it it's spitting out sharp
12 megapixel images with nice dynamic
range and colors a bit overexposed
sometimes that's where it misses but
generally these are nice photos also
sorry in advance for slightly less
outdoor photos the whole shelter in
place quarantine thing clearly means i
also have less people subjects but yeah
you can tell this isn't a confident nice
camera no autofocus issues at all
especially when you give it some light
and even sometimes when you don't it's
nice i like it you are still gonna get
more fringing with close-up subjects i
take a lot of close-up subject photos
and that's the downside of a big one
over 1.4 inch sensor but again that just
seems like par for the course for
flagship cameras right now big sensor
usually sharp photos but get some
fringing when your photos are close up
subjects the night mode is pretty good
which is nice
max zoom is 30x from that telephoto
camera i don't think it's very usable at
30x it's barely passable galaxy s20
ultra is still going to be the zoom
champ for that sort of range but hey 10x
is fine and 3x is definitely usable
and i have pretty much no use for the
hat color filter camera uh the selfie
camera you guys have asked for it i
usually don't get too into the selfie
camera and smart phones but i'll do it
i'll start taking selfies now it's part
of the job and i gotta say this one
still seems to struggle with proper
exposure and maybe that's gonna happen
more for people with darker skin like
myself but other than that it's still
looking pretty good with detail
and video from this camera is also good
especially with color and stabilization
at 4k and you can see no 8k video here
but you know you're not touching the
iphone when it comes to the absolute
best video quality in a phone right now
but this is still good flagship quality
color me impressed i think uh i think
some people took me saying that the
camera was the worst part of the phone
last year as like some sort of horrific
flaw in it when really it was like the
rest of the phone was so incredibly good
that the
okay camera was the downside but again
now we're looking at a flagship quality
camera and they've also been notoriously
pretty good with updating them over time
and getting better with camera quality
that's been nice plus there'll probably
be a gcam mod in the next couple weeks
hopefully if you want those sweet pixel
contrasty photos so
yeah thumbs up on the camera and then
oneplus phones have long been some of my
favorites specifically because of the
software and optimized experience this
is oxygen os on top of android 10 and
that's no exception here for this phone
there's tons of little tweaks and
optimizations and improvements and
little tightened up animations all over
the place but it never feels overloaded
like some other overlays they actually
removed the oxygen os shelf to the left
of the home screen and it's just
google's discover page now like a pixel
and there's really high quality haptics
in this phone again i love that and then
in software there's just a couple new
software features here and there that
are nicely executed there's a new dark
mode 2.0 theme
some new dynamic wallpapers tucked in
there and just a lot of aesthetic tweaks
generally but they do a good job of not
feeling overly cartoony and then there's
a new
motion graphics smoothing toggle that
works with certain apps you can see the
whole compatibility list here for my
phone and it worked pretty well when i
tried it for like two minutes but i feel
like i'm against
motion smoothing like on principle at my
core so i turned that off pretty quick
but you might remember that what's on my
phone video with the galaxy s20 where i
go through all the things that i do the
little subtle software tweaks to really
make it
my daily driver and make it behave the
way i want that list of things is so
much shorter on a phone like the oneplus
8 pro or a pixel
and yeah this this is going to be my new
daily driver so long story short they
finally made a flagship they finally did
it they're charging flagship money and
they're offering pretty much everything
a flagship would
uh in a bona fide complete
kind of predictable feeling way but
still it's what we're looking forward to
matter of fact let me put my predictions
down for the oneplus 8t pro that'll
probably come out in like six to eight
months you're probably looking at
snapdragon 865 plus
maybe a little extra ram
uh probably faster charging faster qi
wireless charging i also think maybe
they could use a little bit of a darker
coating on the selfie camera up in the
corner
and maybe a special mclaren edition
phone and that's it but in the meantime
this becomes one of the easiest phones
to recommend period
even though it's the most expensive
oneplus phone ever which is a nice
headline to write
it still undercuts a lot of the other
flagships that it's now at feature
parity with and i think this is
definitely the one you should pick of
those
either way that's been it thanks for
watching
catch you guys the next one
peace